let's say that we know that this area
under the curve y is equal to f of X let
me label it y is equal to f of X so
under this curve above the x-axis
between a and B which we denote as the
definite integral from A to B of f of X
D of X let's say we know what this is
let's say it's equal to I don't know
let's say this area is equal to 5 so
given that can you figure out what the
definite integral what the definite
integral from the definite integral from
a plus some constant C let me do this in
a different color so what is going to be
the definite integral of f of X minus C
DX from a plus C to B plus C so this
might look a little daunting but I
encourage you to kind of try to
visualize what's going to happen you try
to pick a C in your brain and try to
graph them and pause the video try to
think about what this is going to be
given what we know about this so I'm
assuming you've had a go at it so what
is f of X minus C well that's
essentially the function f of X shifted
to the right by C so let's do that so
that's going to look like so if we take
that function we shift it to the right
let's say that let's say that this
distance right over here is C so if you
shift it to the right by C it's going to
look something like that so I just
copied and pasted my original one it's
going to look something like that and I
can even color code it let me give it a
so this thing right over here this is
the graph of this is the graph of y is
equal to Y is equal to f of X minus C
and so all I did it really just shifts
everything over by C it just shifted
everything shifted everything over shift
it everything over by by C and you wrote
you in one way to Ramin this is
something you probably learned in
precalculus class or an algebra class
and the key thing to realize is okay
when X is e
to see you're essentially inputting so
when X is equal to C when X is equal to
C you're inputting 0 because you're
gonna get C minus C you're going to get
input 0 into F so you're gonna get the
same value here when F so when X is
equal to C for X minus C you're
inputting 0 into the function you get
the same value there as when you just
took the function and you just input it
0 into it so that's some of the logic
why when you take X minus C you're
shifting to the right by C now let's
think about the bounds here this is a
plus C so a plus let's shift so a plus C
is going to get us right over there
roughly and so this is a plus C and B
plus C is going to get us is going to
get us right over here so this point
right over here is B plus C so our new
bounds our new bounds look like this our
new bounds we're going to go from A plus
C to B plus C and so this is the area
actually let me do it in that yellow
color since that's what I made the
definite integral in so we care about
this area now we care about this area
and I think it might starting to jump
out at you what this is going to be
equal to this right over here is going
to be this exact thing we just shifted
everything we shifted the function to
the right we shifted the balance to the
right and so this is going to be the
same thing as the integral from A to B
of f of X DX which in this case and I
just kind of made that up in this case
it's going to be equal to 5 but the
important thing to realize this is a
tricky one you'll see this sometimes
sometimes in math competitions or in
kind of a difficult test but sometimes
it can actually help you solve an
integral once again if you're tackling a
really well as we'll see in the future
we'll tackle some really interesting
problems we're identifying this can be
valuable you might say hey wait this is
some bizarre thing how do I figure this
out and just realize well this is just
shifting this this is just shifting this
area over to the right by C so it's
going to have the exact same the exact
same value
you